françois costantini bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france une
défaite vécue comme une humiliation
nationale par certains l'accord conclu
par l'arménie sous l'égide de moscou lui
est il réellement défavorable bonsoir
oui cet accord est intervenu en quelque
sorte au moment où l'arménie était au
bord du précipice
alors l'accord en quelque sorte sauvé
l'arménie et sauver le lot karabakh mais
à quel prix c'est à dire que d'une part
l'arménie a perdu tout bénéfice des
conquêtes de 1992 1994 sur le
l'azerbaïdjan elle opte aujourd'hui
qu'un corridor qui est contrôlé par par
la russie et elle a perdu pratiquement
25 30 30% du territoire du du haut
karabakh
donc c'est un accord en effet qui marque
un recul pour la parfois de l'arménie
depuis l'accession à l'indépendance il
ya 30 ans l'armée se joint désormais à
l'opposition pour demander la démission
de nikol pashinian les militaires qui
avait pourtant soutenu l'accord de
cessez-le-feu dans le haut-karabagh
pourquoi ces changements de position je
pense que visiblement on est sur une
tendance longue c'est à dire qu'il faut
remonter déjà à 2018
l'arrivée au pouvoir de nikol pashinian
qui qui s'est fait également dans un
contexte de division ou de
manifestations et je pense qu'il ya
également un bilan donc aujourd'hui que
l'arménie dresse un bilan tout à fait
catastrophique dramatique de a été
l'armé depuis 25 ans est-ce que
parallèlement est venu laser abrasion
d'ailleurs qu' il ya une décroissance
démographique en arménie baisse de
l'armement une activité diplomatique
alors que dans l'autre côté
l'azerbaïdjan puisse à sa population
croître 1 aujourd'hui il faut rappeler
c'est pas la moindre des choses il ya
trois azerbaïdjanais pour un arménien
elle s'est armée de façon convenable à
renouer les liens avec la turquie à la
faveur notamment de l'arrivée devrait
être chapelle perdent ou gagnent au
pouvoir à ankara
elle a une politique
me d'armement avec la russie avec la
turquie avec israël
et donc c'est une en fait eu un
effondrement de la géopolitique de la
politique la diplomatie de la vision
stratégique de l'arménie qui est
aujourd'hui sanctionner à ce que selon
vous le premier ministre arménien à a
commis des erreurs en termes de
politique extérieure pour l'arménie
de façon générale je pense qu'on ne
s'est pas occupé de ce conflit vous
savez qu'il existait depuis 1994 le
groupe de contact contact de minsk
coprésidé alors par la france la russie
et les etats unis ce groupe n'a jamais
été activé et qu'on aurait dû peut-être
d'ailleurs pensé à une solution
pacifique et durable avec un retrait
progressif de l'armée ni des territoires
ddt azerbaïdjan et en contrepartie
connaissance de la la souveraineté
arméniennes du haut karabakh
la question c'est réglé hélas pour
l'harmonie par le feu et de sang
auparavant par le confit et on peut
considérer que l'armée ne s'est pas bien
préparé à ce conflit avec peut-être un
relâchement des liens des liens avec la
russie avec une absence de vision vision
géopolitique et puis il volonté d'être
figée sur les déposer sur 25 ans la
dernière question rapidement un
changement de pouvoir comme demandé par
l'opposition pour est il relancé le
conflit contre l'azerbaïdjan est ce que
c'est un risque qui existe à court terme
certainement pas vous savez à court
terme je pense que l'arménie aujourd'hui
panse ses plaies el assa tant de douleur
elle doit accueillir plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de réfugiés venus du
haut-karabakh sur son territoire qui ont
fui les territoires désormais sous la
sous la tutelle directe
de bakou aujourd'hui l'arménie en est
plutôt aarau à se recomposer seront
considérés plutôt qu'une reprise du
conflit
ensuite je pense que les protagonistes
moloko locaux la turquie et puis la
russie également n'y ont pas intérêt du
fait qu'ils ont ils sont quand même
arrivés à aa conclura non concluant un
accord et qu'aujourd'hui ils ont plutôt
leur préoccupation consiste plutôt à la
mise en place de l'accord merci beaucoup
françois post signé d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
l géopolitologue